This can happen in a cross
site scripting attack.
Here's an example.
The user has logged into
a vulnerable site, naive.com.
And his browser now stores
the cookie from naive.com.
The user is then phished and
clicks a URL to visit evil.com.
Evil.com returns a page that has
a hidden frame that forces the browser
to visit naive.com and
invoke hello.cgi web application
on naive.com with a malicious
script as the name of the user.
When the user's browser displays
the HTML page from evil.com,
he will be forced to visit naive.com and
call hello.cgi with this malicious
script as the user's name.
Hello.cgi at naive.com then
echoes the malicious script
in the HTML page that is sent
back to the user's browser.
The user's browser displays the HTML
page and executes the malicious script.
The result is that the cookie
to naive.com is stolen and
sent to the attacker.
You may ask, so what?
If evil.com gets
the cookie to naive.com?
Because that cookie can include
session authentication information for
naive.com.
Therefore, by stealing the cookie the
attacker can now impersonate the user.